all right here's something empowering
too one more thing before we get to the
comments Subways from Forbes Subway the
international quick service restaurant
chain is offering free sandwiches for
life to one lucky winner who agrees to
legally change their first name to
Subway and said Tuesday nearly 10 000
people answered the call in just four
days this is not the first time Subway
has asked fans to commit Outrageous Acts
in exchange for free sandwiches in 2022
Subway gave James Coons of Fort Collins
Colorado free sandwiches for Life via 50
000 a gift card after he got a 12 by 12
Inch tattoo of the logo of of Subway's
latest promotion the Subway Series
it's amazing there are people that are
this loyal to the subway brand I mean a
fifty thousand dollar gift card to
Subway is not a gift it's a punishment
it's like a life sentence because Subway
is awful
and I'm not even just talking about the
whole thing where they made their brand
uh synonymous with a pedophile and yet
people still want to change their name
to it which is
uh amazing but the product itself is
also terrible like every Subway
smells weird to begin with they don't
they don't smell like fresh bread or
deli meat I don't know what that smell
is they smell bizarre they smell like
sadness uh they smell I've never been
inside one but they smell to me like the
the maybe the employee break room at a
DM like a DMV I don't know why they just
they do I I can't explain that they do
and the bread is always stale
the deli meat tastes like it's been
sitting at room temperature since last
Wednesday because it was the lettuce is
wilted the green prep Peppers taste like
E coli
the service is usually terrible the
employees are High I mean they put these
things in gas stations so you got a guy
that was just cleaning up a gas Billet
pump 12 now making your Italian BMT and
uh don't get me wrong I'll still eat it
like I was just at a subway a couple
days ago so I'll still eat there because
I'm a fat American shoveling garbage
into my face but that doesn't change the
fact that it's bad
which is why everyone is like angry at
Subway I don't know if you've noticed
that when you're outside no one is it's
not it's not it's not like a Jersey
Mike's or Firehouse Subs where there's
some there's some life and laughter when
you go in at Subway everyone's mad while
they're eating their stale bread and
their Oscar Meyer mystery meat
and this is what you want your name to
be
just you can eat there for life
Jared ate at Subway every day for years
and look what he turned into so
I rest my case hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there